cette vidéo est sponsorisée par ce qu'il
cherchent plus d'informations en fin de
vidéo les émotions bonne nouvelle on
parle en Afrique du sud face Fiona et
moi avoue c'est par procuration et tout
ça c'est grâce à vous en quelques heures
à peine vous avez franchi les 100% de
notre crotte founding pour rejoindre
Julien notre acte science en Afrique du
Sud pour sa campagne de fouille
paléontologique avec ses étudiants merci
merci merci merci merci à tous de vous
offrir ces vacances ce stage de terrain
vous êtes des légendes ça m'inquiète un
peu que vous ayez été aussi enthousiaste
à l'idée de m'envoyer le plus loin
possible au beau milieu d'un désert mais
j'apprécie le geste je crois or donc
maintenant que c'est sûr on va en
Afrique du Sud pour de bon on s'est dit
avec Julien que que faudrait que je
freine sur la coque on se dirait que
Julien que ce serait pas du luxe de vous
détailler notre programme sur place
alors demandez le programme voilà à
quels sont va être mangé gribiche
d'abord on va faire des fouilles dans
les niveaux du Trias près de béthus là
où on trouve des listes et des
sinognatus c'est là qu'on va se faire la
main Julien et les autres profs nous
apprendront à prospecter à fouiller et
aplatrer les faux cils qu'on aura trouvé
ensuite on va au viston pour admirer la
limite Permien Trias cette fameuse
limite continue qu'on trouve qu'en Chine
et ici cette limite c'est ce qui
matérialise l'extinction de masse la
plus importante qu'on connaisse celle
qui rayée de la carte près de 90% des
espèces vivantes parce que les espèces
mortes quant à Fiona elle en profitera
pour prendre un cours de fossilisation
auprès de ses copains décédés qui n'ont
pas pris une ride depuis des millions
d'années non parce que vous avez pas
l'odeur en vidéo mais ça commence à
devenir un peu critique cette affaire
ensuite on ira claire friends un éminent
professeur spécialiste de l'équivalent
de l'archéologie préventive mais pour la
paléontologie qui s'appelle le
paléontological impact c'est l'un des
débouchés les plus accessibles aux
jeunes paléontologues sud-africains et
je vous parie que vous l'ignoriez et ça
tombe bien parce que moi aussi c'est
justement l'occasion d'en savoir plus si
petite visite au Golden Gate house
National Park et de ses fossiles de
dinosaures notamment une dalle de tresse
de pas de Dino j'espère que Fiona pourra
nous faire un petit selfie devant les
empreintes et grâce à votre ardeur pour
les cailloux on a même déjà pu franchir
un palier supplémentaire du creux de
founding alors où je vous parle on a
même dépassé les 10000 euros c'est
complètement censé 10000 fois le PIB de
la Grèce on va donc pouvoir prendre
encore plus d'étudiants avec nous et
vous avez débloquer des destinations
bonus dont certaines dont je vous
parlais dans une vidéo précédente on va
donc rester non pas deux semaines mais
20 jours sur le terrain et faire un
crochet pour aller voir les fameux faire
rubaner les beefs ces roches rouges qui
se sont formés à la suite de
l'apparition des premiers organismes
photosynthétiques sur terre cela même
qui ont initialement créé l'oxygène
qu'on respire aujourd'hui on ira lécher
le crayon du Transvaal l'un des plus
vieux morceaux de croûte terrestres et
l'un des rats à ne pas s'être fait
aspirer dans les profondeurs de la terre
par le biais de la tectonique des
plaques et puis comme si c'était pas
assez incroyable on ira aussi visiter
l'intérieur du cratère de TWING prénom
Shania un magnifique cratère de
météorite de 1 km de diamètre qui s'est
formé lors de l'impact d'un bolide il y
a seulement 2020 en pas du tout prouver
que j'ai rien j'ai rien 220 000 ans et
une grotte fossilifère au cœur du
berceau de l'humanité l'un des gisements
les plus riches en vieux humains après
le terrain de pétanque de mon village et
là ont été retrouvés notamment pas mal
d'australopithèque parmi les plus beaux
et les plus importants que connaissent
voilà donc le programme pour l'instant
déjà c'est tout bonnement taille de zgeg
on va voir en vrai des trucs que je rêve
de voir depuis que j'ai appris leur
existence avant-hier en vrai pendant mes
études je crois que ça remonte au bar et
miens rendez-vous compte des défauts
cils des beefs un craquant secrétaire de
météorites je vous jure j'en suis toute
chose tant de vieux cailloux à lécher
j'y serai plus donner de la tête donc
vraiment merci on vous en ai infiniment
reconnaissant mais c'est pas tout devant
votre enthousiasme on s'est dit qu'on
allait vous pomper encore plus de Tunas
c'est pas nous c'est l'inflation et on
ajoute donc un palier supplémentaire au
crotte funding si vraiment vous savez
pas quoi faire de votre argent pensez à
cet investissement robustement bénéfique
si vous atteignez cette boutique somme
de 15000 euros on vous propose de tuer
ce voyage avec des spinners et un
caisson de basse dans le coffre
c'est-à-dire aller voir la fameuse mine
de diamants de Kimberley et là on aura
le bingo au complet j'espère qu'on
pourra repartir avec des petits
souvenirs et je suis sûre que les
étudiantes Julien seront aussi ravis de
voir que leur région Russell tout ces
trésors dans son intimité c'est pas dit
qu'ils connaissent parfaitement leur
propre région et si je peux leur white
planer leur patrimoine géologique je le
ferai avec grand plaisir dans son infini
pédagogique Julien qu'on vit trois
chercheurs supplémentaires sur le
terrain qui sont des des as de certaines
techniques de fouilles pour le plus
grand bonheur des étudiants qui sont un
peu là pour se former pendant que je les
regarderai bosser sous mon parasol un
cocktail à la main votre plus grand
bonheur aussi à vous parce que je compte
bien vous partager ce qu'il faut pour
que vous puissiez reproduire toute cette
technique dans votre jardin sur les
restes de votre toutou vous avez enterré
là il y a 10 ans au pied de votre chaîne
de mon côté j'aimerais pimper un peu mon
matériel audiovisuel pour vous faire les
plus belles images possibles et le son
aussi parce qu'à l'heure actuelle j'ai
pas le bon micro pour faire du reportage
bref pas mal de petits trucs à acheter
et en échange je vous propose non pas
une mais deux vidéos sur ma chaîne
réalisées sur place pour vous emmener
toujours plus loin à la découverte des
merveilleux cailloux sud-africains et de
tout ce qui nous apprennent sur
l'histoire de la Terre
en complément de ces vidéos longues je
ferai aussi une série de vidéos short en
format vertical ça c'est une spéciale
pour mon public boomer je sais que vous
adorez celle là dans un esprit un peu
plus léger pour vous partager notre
quotidien sur le terrain ou bien des
anecdotes insolites que j'aurais pu
glaner au fil de nos découvertes petit à
dents d'hommes pour des raisons de sa
capte pas au milieu du désert mais que
fait Elon Musk toutes les vidéos seront
publiées à mon retour d'Afrique du Sud
vous pourrez donc suivre nos aventures
en direct mais mais pas le même jour en
pas direct du tout donc et en plus on
vous propose des super contreparties
pour ce crossfunding oui je vais faire
cette blague à chaque fois pendant citer
que quelques unes pour 20 euros vous
aurez accès aux photos des fouilles
toutes les coulisses y compris et
surtout les dossiers pour 50 euros vous
pourrez nommer une nouvelle espèce si on
découvre une nouvelle espèce en
fouillant ce qui est assez fréquent
d'après Julien vous participerez au vote
lors du choix du nom qu'il a entra pour
l'éternité pour 300 euros je vous envoie
un tirage signé et numéroté d'un des
croquis que j'aurais réalisé sur place
voilà quelques exemples des
gribouillages que je peux faire pour
vous donner une idée et que vous
puissiez jauger si vous l'afficherez
plutôt dans votre salon ou dans vos
cabinets
[Musique]
vous reconnaissez
c'est que quelques exemples il y a plein
d'autres contreparties je laisse aller
voir directement sur la page Lulu le
lien est en description et dans les
commentaires ça vous fait pas envie tout
ça moi ça me
si vous voulez contribuer à cette
aventure vous avez jusqu'au 5 juillet
pour participer à notre crotte funding
si le cœur vous en dit dans tous les cas
c'est sûr on part en Afrique du Sud et
Julien Fiona et moi on vous en est
infiniment reconnaissant et les
étudiants du lien accessoirement on a
tous un petit peu hâte je pense que ça
s'entend un peu merci d'avoir rendu
cette expédition possible et le sponsor
de cette vidéo ton baptique tel Shania
Twain car il s'agit de ce qu'il cherche
ce qu'il cherche c'est une plateforme
qui propose des milliers de cours en
ligne en illimité sur une grande variété
de sujets du jardinage à la production
de vidéos YouTube en passant par la
photo l'animation le crochet le dessin
botanique la théorie musicale la
calligraphie le développement web
l'étalonnage ça je vais très vite les
regarder pour notre bien tous la poésie
la cuisine bref si vous êtes un minimum
créatif et quel que soit votre niveau
vous devriez trouver votre bonheur et
moi qui adore apprendre des trucs et qui
aime bien toucher à tout donc c'est
majeur j'étais déjà très fan des tutos
en ligne et des MOOC les cours en ligne
proposés par les facs je peux vous dire
que j'ai sauté sur l'occasion de tester
le site pour l'instant j'en suis ravie
j'y étais encore hier à 2h du mat je
vous parlais de mes croquis de terrain
tout à l'heure justement je suis tombé
sur le cours votre monde à l'aquarelle
une approche méditative de la peinture
de paysage par Rosalie ezley une artiste
américaine qui nous explique cette
technique et qui nous emmène sur le
terrain avec elle pour peindre entre
deux visites de vautours c'est là que
j'ai appris l'existence et l'importance
du point focale dans la composition de
son dessin je vous spoile pas tout mais
en gros c'est ce qui explique que ce
dessin sympa mais voilà et celui-là est
un peu plus intéressant du point de vue
de la composition
certains cours sont en VO française mais
de toute façon quelle que soit la langue
de départ tous les cours sont
sous-titrés en français j'ai pas fini
tout explorer encore d'autant plus qu'il
rajoute des nouveaux cours toutes les
semaines c'est Boog là par exemple j'ai
enchaîné avec un cours pour apprendre
l'écriture de non-fiction par une
journaliste du New Yorker rien que ça
vous aussi si vous voulez plonger dans
le catalogue de formation ce qu'il cher
j'offre un mois d'essai gratuit au 1000
premières personnes qui cliqueront sur
le lien en description vous en direz des
nouvelles allez près feu partez
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui un grand
merci pour votre engouement si vous
voulez participer à l'aventure
sud-africaine je rappelle que vous avez
jusqu'au 5 juillet pour contribuer au
creux de founding et peut-être nous
faire passer le prochain palier dans
tous les cas c'est sûr on va en Afrique
du Sud et Julien va pouvoir emmener les
futurs paléontologues sud-africains sur
le terrain et ça c'est grâce à vous
j'espère que vous êtes fier de vous
maintenant il y a plus qu'à digne de
votre enthousiasme et essayer de ne pas
mourir tout de suite dans le désert face
au four Fiona elle est tranquille
allez c'est tranquille
[Musique]